the winner is probably going to be a
small group of people it's going to be
open AI it's going to be maybe anthropic
it's going to be like these large
companies that will raise a ton of money
and have a ton of GPU capacity to
basically build the best and build and
train the best models I think and I
think that that's more of a zero summed
game than most people think and so where
I think becomes interesting is like
building on top of these platforms
people who can sort of like skin these
models in a way that you know my
grandmother could use for instance um
like to me that be sounds like very
interesting all right guys bang bang I
have praying for exits yes it's not his
real name but he is one of probably the
most interesting early stage investors
in Tech right now uh we're going to do a
little round robin I figured i' just
throw out a couple of Industries and we
could talk about what you're excited
about what opportunities you're seeing
and then maybe companies you're not
seeing but you wish that someone would
go and start we can start with defense
technology obviously Ander is kind of
the Grilla in the room people have
gotten very very very excited about what
they're doing uh but defense Tech is not
just andero there's tons of other
companies what are you excited about in
that space yeah I think that like and
again thanks for having me pump um I
think that what's really exciting is and
and I guess like it's it's kind of a f
like a fine line here but um you know
the macro picture has kind of shown that
defense Technologies are increasingly
becoming more important and maybe our
day-to-day lives in a way that most
people in the valley probably didn't
think that they would 20 years ago um
and I I think what's really interesting
is there was sort of a lot of brave
people uh like Palmer um the guys at
Shield AI who kind of like pushed the
envelope on um you know developing
defense Technologies and for all intents
and purposes you know this is what
Silicon Valley was built on you know you
have loed and raon and all of these
early Silicon Valley companies taking
all of the best talent out of the valley
and and building interesting things I
think we're coming back to a place where
that's reaching prominence again um I
think the shift away from you know
defense techn techologies being sort of
like a bad word in the valley to a place
where some of the most Innovative and
interesting people are spending their
time has been one that has been really
quick and I think the backdrop of the
macroeconomic picture has kind of sped
that up and so what I'm seeing that's
really interesting right now is
obviously there's a bunch of offensive
and defensive technologies that are
super interesting and that have becoming
um you know a lot more pushed the more
sort of the center of the cultural
Zeitgeist as it were through people like
Palmer um but what you're starting to
see is a lot of these ancillary
technologies that are supportive of um
some of these like larger companies like
andril um there's one company that I
just did that's you know um like
infrastructure supporting defense um
there's another one that I'm doing
that's building a new drone platform um
there's another guy that is is has
become quite popular on Twitter who's
thinking about using weather as a weapon
um I think that there's all of these
really interesting young kids who are
who are who are leaning into defense as
an interesting industry and um it seems
really exciting exting there's there's a
lot of innovation and there's a lot of
new things popping up and and it's a
really interesting place to play so
defense is one of these interesting
Industries where you've got to
understand kind of what is our current
capabilities what is the threats that we
may face uh offensive and defensive uh
you know kind of capabilities um and
then also How likely is it that one of
these crazy Technologies can actually be
built right and so if you take Andro as
an example they're basically like hey
we're just going to build cool
right was kind of like an initial pitch
that's going to go solving some of these
problem
now you look at the team and you've got
some of the best technologist of the
last few decades and so it's like okay
High odds or probability they're going
to be successful when you start looking
at like using weather as a weapon which
I'm pretty sure I know exactly which
company you're talking about it makes
sense that okay if you could do ab and C
then yes you will be able to have this
new capability how do you underwrite can
this group of people actually pull it
off and what is the technical
feasibility of a said technology yeah I
think what's interesting about defense
is you kind of have to underwrite it in
two different ways at once and try and
get a clear picture off the back of that
I think the first way that you have to
underwrite is to your point is this
technology viable is the person who's
building this technology the person who
can kind of get this to scale and make
it useful within the context of uh the
government or private Enterprise and
then the other aspect of it that is like
a lot more difficult to underwrite and I
think historically has kept people from
investing in defense more is how do you
underwrite the likelihood that the US
government plays ball right um and I
think that one of the you know it's
never really place that you want to be
in in sort of like investing is you know
is the US government on my side with
this one um but increasingly I think
that it's important at least for people
or I think that it's underrated um like
an underrated Endeavor and trying to
understand this better and and people
who just start out with defense is that
they don't really have a good sense of
how the government Machine Works how
contracts are you know won and and and
lost um you know how lobbying Works uh
how all of these different things affect
um the outcomes of your Investments and
I think that people like uh Palmer and
and uh somebody like Joe lale at paler
these guys kind of kick the door down
and kind of set the um sort of framework
for how to do it and so I think that now
more than ever it's a little bit easier
to underwrite you know something like
how does weather work in a weapons
system uh just because you know those
Frameworks were established by companies
like cener and andril um but over time
um I think that this becomes a lot
easier to understand
whereas right now it's still a little
bit obtuse and I think that there's
still value there and understanding what
works and what doesn't in that context
on defense Tech it also seems like
there's two other components that are
driving you know kind of a huge influx
of uh successful companies one is like
Tech figured out how to settle the
government and now that's like a
Playbook and people kind of understand
how to do it and then two is uh there is
like uh I think people are calling it
The paler pack right there's like people
who went they're part of a successful
company they start to spin out and start
more companies compies and so like
success but gets more success some of
that is Talent some of that is the
network that gets built out so you have
people to recruit some of that is the
playbooks talk a little bit as to like
how you start to really understand like
okay is this a two three decades long
Trend that we're about to see here that
really kicks off because some of those
people kicked down the door and now
there are kind of playbooks and networks
that that are established yeah I think I
think you see it in in kind of different
Industries with sort of high bars to
this inter dis intermediation I think
the F early great first example of it is
sort of PayPal um you know Financial
Services where these sort of Byzantine
very difficult uh process um
that uh you know had a high bar to entry
back when Peter and those guys tried to
do it and um I think that you know
defense is now this new one where um
sort of the bar has been quite high like
been raised quite High uh or was quite
High originally and now you know to your
point the doors have been broken down a
little and what you're starting to see
especially in Los Angeles I think um you
know in South Bay there's a Cambrian
explosion of uh people who used to work
at the large defense companies so
whether it's andil or you know not
saying SpaceX is a defense company but
Aerospace defense you know they kind of
exist within um this Paradigm of like a
new company that's sort of breaking
things and and sort of Paving the way um
and then they see all of these
interesting pockets of value that other
people from the outside looking in might
not see and then they tend to start
companies around them and so um yeah
there's like uh for instance there's a
really popular deal that was just done
not too long ago that's focuses on wire
harnessing which is running wire cables
through all all the hard tech um you
know that's that's happening out here
and so yeah I think there's a cambering
explosion of of interesting things
happening in Los Angeles specifically
for to that point that you made which is
um you know these companies have great
uh employees that work there early find
these pockets of value that nobody are
really thinking about leave and start
new companies and you're starting to see
that at andil you're starting to see
that it's basx you know people who've
been there for 5 10 years bested all
their Equity now have this you know new
idea that they want to pursue and and
they're going out to start a company
around it and you know uh it's one of
the hottest sort of sectors in our in
our Market that we play in and you know
there's a a bunch of like really young
sort of sub 30-year-old kids who are
building really interesting things right
now through that context let's talk
Aerospace as a second industry uh there
is some overlap with defense obviously
but there is a whole sector of that has
nothing to do with this fence what are
you seeing in the Aerospace industry
that's exciting or areas of opportunity
yeah some investor in companies like VA
um you know do do some work with with
the SpaceX guys um I think that again I
think that Aerospace is a little bit
earlier along the defense curve um or a
little bit uh a little bit less
developed than the defense curve right
now and why I say that is you know
there's a ton of satellite companies
coming out satellite bus companies
people like vaa who are doing
interesting things in low orbit space um
I think think that in the way that
defense wasn't necessarily clearly
established on like what are the
platforms that have scalability uh over
the long term I think Aerospace is kind
of reaching that moment right now you
you've seen a bunch of companies that
have raised large amounts of money to
you know launch low like satellite buses
or do these things um it to me it's very
difficult to tell which of these
platforms ends up with high scalability
because a lot of these things like vaa
for instance V is making factories in
low orbit space you know the total
addressable market for that is probably
quite large but I think that that market
is probably pretty uneducated on you
know how to utilize that technology to
its Max potential and so I think that
we're still in the learning curve
section of Aerospace specifically where
you know a bunch of people are trying
things they're raising a bunch of money
around it sending things into the space
and you know or doing things like mock
um or or like you know doing electric
planes and all these different things
and I think it remains to be seen which
one of these is the sort of Paradigm
that really um becomes valuable from a a
monetary standpoint but I think that
there's a bunch of really interesting
people trying a bunch of really
interesting things in that space as well
and the overlap between defense and
Aerospace seems to be tightening quite a
bit or at least returning to where it
used to be uh back in the uh you know
like Howard Hughes kind of days and so
um yeah I think there's a really a bunch
of of really interesting stuff happening
there right now and it's place has spend
quite a bit of time when you look at the
Aerospace industry it seems like uh
there's a technology component I think
of like boom Supersonic and you know
some of these companies that are really
trying to push uh what what is possible
I think V is in that category Etc
there's also a layer of like regulation
that seems to be um a little bit more
onerous than maybe some of these other
Industries maybe even more so than like
the defense industry how do you think
through a team and and kind of the
Dynamics of like hey we need some
technologist we need obviously people
who can kind of manage and do operations
do we need people in the beginning who
know how to work around regulation and
kind of interact with these regulatory
bodies or or is that something maybe
investors could help with and you know
make it a little bit easier for some of
these teams as they're really focused on
kind of going from zero to one on the
technology side yeah I think it it I
think that it either has to be somebody
on the team or an investor I think that
in the same way that you have to build
something from the ground up very
intentionally in in any industry um
Aerospace is one where you have to do
that with a special special amount of
care um I think that to your point
people like the FFA FAA and and some of
these other three-letter Industries are
you know very difficult to deal with and
I think that they're extremely difficult
to deal with retroactively unless you're
building proactively towards a place
where you know that they'll play ball I
think that you run the risk of basically
gambling on whether or not something
will work uh well not even from a
technical standpoint and this kind of
goes back to understanding both
Technical and sort of
um uh just sort of like government um
feasibility um I think that you know I
think that you have to start building
from the point of view of like hey I
know exactly what is going to work or at
least have a high confidence interval of
what these people are going to be
willing to see and if you don't sort of
build it from the ground up in that way
I think that you run the risk of you
know two years down the line you have a
technology that's technically viable um
but not practically viable and so um
I've seen a lot of companies raise a
bunch of money and build these beautiful
technically beautiful things um but then
they get to the point where they have to
sell it to somebody and um you know it's
for one reason or another um you know
blocked or push down or you know slowed
down um and and that can be kind of like
a death nail for for an early stage
company and so I always recommend to
just build with the intention of like
hey we are interactive with you know
these regulatory bodies from the very
beginning um even at the precede and so
you have to build the company in that
that way so that you know two years down
the line you don't have to sort of
reverse engineer how to make something
successful instead of you know building
it building towards it that makes sense
artificial intelligence another industry
that seems to be getting tons and tons
of Interest right now uh one Camp is
artificial intelligence going to change
the world it's the most disruptive
technology since the internet uh another
Camp is like you guys are all idiots and
this is the most overhyped overblown
thing in the history of Technology uh
where do you kind of fall on this and
how do you tell maybe both are true and
you got to through through the noise to
to find the companies that aren't going
to be overhyped and will actually create
value today's episode is brought to you
by trust and will I've gone through a
number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wills and estate planning come into play
now most people what they do is to get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five-star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trust and will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trust and will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp yeah
I think that I'm not like an absolutist
in in that way I think a lot of people
on the Internet seem to be though in the
sense that um you know most people
either think that this will be the
greatest thing that's ever happened to
us in our lifetimes or um it's kind of
this overhyped space that maybe is like
akin to you know like how people talk
about a crypto or um to me it seems a
lot more like and and I have nothing
wrong with crypto I think it was a
paradigmatic change I just think that it
got kind of overrun by sort of people
who you know didn't have the best
interests of the platform at heart um
but I think that um it's it's this it's
clearly a paradigmatic shift that's
going to change a lot of the way that um
people you know conduct business I don't
know I think that like the application
layer is what's most interesting to me
but it also seems the most scary because
anything that you do in the application
layer seems as though it can be
disintermediated by open AI at any point
um and it seems like there there's been
a variety of uh there's been a variety
of companies that seem to go out of
business every single day that openi uh
released a new update like for instance
two or three days maybe earlier this
week um they released the PDF reader you
know and they released open eye voice
and each time they release one of these
things you know like 25 startups die um
or at least are forced to sort of
aggressively pivot and so to me I think
that like you know the model at the
model layer it's going to approve to
like a couple of large players in my
opinion it's just very tough to keep up
to their you know GPU capacity their
talent levels their ability to higher
that seems like pretty strong Moes um at
least on the model on the model side uh
but I think at the application layer um
there's a lot of things that we're
probably not even thinking about that
are going to increasingly be useful
whether it's on the generative side
whether it's on the llm side and so to
me what becomes interesting is like it
seems like another app store kind of
moment where it's like it's very clear
the App Store is going to Usher in you
know a new paradigm of like value um but
what are the apps on the App Store that
end up working what are the airbnbs what
are the um Ubers Etc and so I think that
right now we're in the very early
Innings of like figuring out what are
the next great quote unquote apps built
on you know the the platform of of AI
how do you think about where value ends
up acur right obviously there are uh
these very large companies that seem to
Jump Right In I think Adobe was like a
perfect example generative AI comes out
out all of a sudden there's like 20,000
startups who are all like oh my God we
can do generative Ai and photos and
here's my Twist on this um some
investors poured Capital into these
companies other investors were like ah I
don't know Adobe comes out and they're
like well we have distribution we
already have a great business and now
we're going to take these same
Technologies and we're going to roll it
out in those scenarios there's a lot of
people who are like oh Adobe just killed
you know I don't know hundreds of
startups uh we recently saw this with uh
chat GPT and open Ai and they launched
the PDF uh kind of the ability to to
communicate back and forth I saw one of
the founders talking about well actually
he's not going to kill our business
because we have all these you know
unique features when you're investing
how do you understand opportunities but
try to depict do the big guys come in
and Crush these you know smaller
companies by just flipping on these
features or can these smaller companies
use the same technology create actual
Moes and in the early days you're
looking at a pitch deck you're having a
conversation like there's not much to
evaluate and so what's your process to
unpack that
so I think that like my personal
perspective is that um at the model
layer it's probably the winner is
probably going to be a small group of
people it's going to be open AI it's
going to be maybe anthropic it's going
to be like these large companies that
would raised a ton of money and have a
ton of GPU capacity to basically build
the best and build and train the best
models I think and I think that that's
more of a zero summed game than most
people think I think that it's going to
be very difficult to compete with
somebody like an open AI
on that just at scale um and so where I
think becomes interesting is like
building on top of these platforms and
where I think the moat uh becomes useful
is like um what's a good example of of a
company that has a great moat maybe like
mid Journey right um it's like mid
journey is built on top of a bunch of
models I actually don't have the
specific models that it's built on top
of but it's clearly like an application
Level um sort of thing that is become
super useful to people and I think that
even though something like open a comes
out with something like a DOL E3 um
which is is very very interesting very
useful I think people still tend to lean
to Mid Journey because um you know
whether they like that specific art
style or whether they uh find the
process to use mid Journey you know
super useful and they can prompt the
models in a in a in a way that feels
natural I think that there's going to be
a lot for uh consumer usability um and
so I think that people who can sort of
like skin these models in a way that you
know my grandmother could use for
instance um like to me that becomes like
very interesting and creating like a
bunch of uh different sort of
application Level technologies that um
just make the average person a little
bit more useful with these Technologies
seems to be the initial mode that
becomes interesting I think it's very
hard to compete and say hey we will
train the best models with the most
parameters with like I think that that
is is a losing game that the big guys
will continue to win I think that it
becomes interesting what becomes
interesting is not trying to build the
next app store but really trying to
build you know the next uh Robin Hood or
whatever let's talk about the state of
venture capital today uh you've very
focused on the earliest stages how do
you think about uh check sizes and
valuations where we are at the moment
yeah what's interesting and I'm I'm sure
that you've seen this as well and and
feel free to chime in on your own uh
like views on this but I think that what
you're starting to is seed is becoming
quite a lot more competitive and I think
that um it's because a lot of these
later stage funds have realized that you
know it's it's pretty hard to do an a
it's almost impossible to do a b and
then anything at growth is like you have
to be really really careful you're
probably putting a bunch of structure in
it um you're you know protecting your
downside risk all of these things and so
it seems like the late mid to late stage
game has dried up quite a bit and you
see a bunch of these firms you know like
80 billion AUM firms now trying to be
competitive at seed um which is kind of
like a new development and so obviously
you're seeing seed valuations push down
you're seeing sort of later stage
valuations normalize a bit um and so it
feels like there's you know a war zone
kind of happening at seed um it feels
like every single person is chasing
every single hot deal the biggest funds
in the world are spending their time on
$2 million checks um you know it's it
seems super Super Hyper competitive at
seed right now and I think that that's
trickling down even into preed um preed
seems to be a lot more getting a lot
more institutionalized before it was a
bit of the sort of wild wild west people
were just kind of you know doing what
they uh were just kind of like firing
off checks with valuations that were
just kind of like done back back of the
napkin math and now it's a lot more it
seems a lot more structured and like a
lot more people participating in in a
formulated way um so I think that I
spend most of my time at preed and seed
and yeah it feels like to really win the
best deals you have to be very
articulate and about real value that you
can provide rather than hey I'm a seed
investor and there's not many of us so
you better take my money until you wait
for the bigger guys to come
along when there is this more
competition I think it just forces
people early and earlier and one of the
things that uh has been happening
simultaneously is that there are more
and more individuals who can now write
checks uh similar to what we would have
historically called a Super Angel and
you almost get this kind of weird
dynamic where you have individuals who
have become the sizes of small seed
institutions um and they're able to
write checks at the size and velocity at
those institutions so it begs the
question who ends up winning on brand
right the individuals versus um the
actual institutions themselves you
operate under a pseudonym and so you
almost are living kind of in this like
third bucket how do you just think about
okay somebody starting a company it's
obvious that there's a higher
probability of success it's not about
picking it's all about access what are
the pros and cons of the individual
versus the institution versus maybe this
like pseudonym which kind of Blends the
two yeah I think that's a great question
I think that um what you're increasingly
finding is the most Discerning Founders
even at the institution level are still
pursuing specific people in those
institutions and so it's not like hey I
want just seoa but it's hey I want Shawn
Maguire at seoa because Shawn you know
works at DARPA has all these connections
you know I think that increasingly the
advice that you're seeing these young
kids get from people who have done it a
few times before is hey make sure that
the person within the institution that
you want um is the person that is going
to be leading this deal and doing this
deal and I think that um with that in
mind the individual is kind of
prioritized in a lot of ways um even if
they have the platform of a large
institution behind them um and so to me
what's great about being PSE Anonymous
is the reason that I've done the
pseudonymity thing for so long is
because to me it allows the only surface
area for anybody to interact with to be
my ideas or previous work that I've done
that is knowledgeable through the lens
of the pseudonymity and so um what I
increasingly find is like uh to win the
best seed deals you have to be very very
clear on and articulate on what the
value that you are providing to these
Founders are at a granular level and
it's not like these kind of like pie in
the sky oh later on down the line when
you're at series a I'm going to help you
raise no it's like very very practical
needs that are like immediate
um and so I think that the feedback loop
for like who are good seed investors
that provide value whether it be HR
whether it be you know any of these
other things the feedback loop is much
tighter um than it used to be it would
used to be you invested in something in
seed and you had like two years to
before the a to like kind of prove your
worth as a seed investor now it's like
um hey great we took you wired last week
um let's start grinding kind of thing um
and so to me uh being suit Anonymous has
allowed me to really just focus on the
work and less so on like hey look at me
I went to this school I did these deals
back in a previous job or whatever to me
that's all kind of like stupid and
irrelevant um it's it's you're really
only as good as your last deal that
you've done in my opinion and so um yeah
I think that being pit Anonymous allows
a one thing that it also does is it
allows me to play in a place that is
like uh uniquely kind of like um you
know friends with everybody enemies with
nobody um and so I think that that's
really helpful at seed um just because
there's so much to see and so having a
good network of people to parse you know
at least the first level of things for
you is is really helpful too and so yeah
I think that you know my perspective is
that even at the institutional level the
individual and what the individual value
that that person can provide is is the
most useful thing in winning seed deals
and if you can't articulate what that is
you probably aren't offering enough so
what what is the thing that you you know
uh present in terms of the value
proposition
initially the thing that I present in
the value proposition initially and I
think that this is something that you're
quite good at as well is like I kind of
frame it as like hey I work with a bunch
of really technical people who build
incredibly incredibly technical things
I'm not the most technical person myself
but what I am very good at doing is
capturing and retaining attention and I
think that there's a few useful pillars
where attention has become sort of like
increasingly a valuable sort of currency
in in the world that we operate in one
is obviously like hiring right so it's
like hey we have a really interesting
company we have a great Mission we've
been well capitalized why do you want to
come work here how do we capture the
attention of the best Engineers or the
best um hard tech guys or whatever uh to
basically come in and work here uh lead
their jobs elsewhere to come and like
believe in the equity that they'd be
getting as opposed to you know the
salary that they'd be getting so that's
one is like how do you capture the
attention of AR like in from an HR
perspective two is um how do you capture
and retain the attention of investors
right it's like how do you build sort of
like this pedigree around yourself so
that by the time that you go out and
raise your round is basically already
accounted for as opposed to you sort of
going and kicking the tires on a bunch
of firms and taking six months of a
process to basically see if people are
even interested um that's the other side
of it and then the third side of it is
like how do you just get attention on
the things that you built I work with a
bunch of people who are like extremely
technically proficient but when it comes
to getting people to care about this
beautiful thing that they built it's not
their core competence
um and so finding unique and interesting
ways to Leverage The distribution
mechanism of the internet and you know
all of these different social platforms
that increasingly playing uh an
important role in the lives of venture
capis and Founders it's like how do you
just get people to say holy this
guy's building something incredible I
can't wait for it to come out and or I
can't wait for you know this to launch
um I think that that becomes like a
really useful thing and it doesn't seem
like there are many groups there are
some and and I respect them all quite a
lot but there aren't that many groups
that focus on this specific segment of
it all which is you know like go to
market and and in in in kind of a
different sort of way and so um the
value proposition that I provide is like
hey let's capture as much attention as
possible for you and modulate into the
most useful function of it um to to get
your business to where it needs to go
talk a little bit about um why the media
landscape allows you to do this today
right like it used to be that you would
have to go on on television or talk to a
newspaper reporter uh you for all
intents and purposes in the most loving
way you post on Twitter and are
very good at it are able to you know
capture attention and and drive people
to take action what is it that is
different today than maybe five or six
years ago that is allowed for an
opportunity someone like you to to kind
of slip in and now provide this value to
Founders yeah I think it's I think it's
anybody who has a voice on the internet
probably notices this is that like
mainstream media has become increasingly
less useful um it's become increasingly
obvious that you know there's an agenda
behind most things that are shared by
mainstream media and I think this kind
of goes back to something we touched on
earlier which is like the individual
versus the institution I think people
are increasingly more willing to believe
the individual because the uh levers
behind why an individual does something
is probably a little bit more obvious
than the levers of why um like a large
media institution might do something so
to say that you like understand you know
like what the purpose of a New York
Times article is like where what what
you know like the the the editors and
what the different people within the New
York Times were all trying to accomplish
by getting this across that's a lot more
obuse than saying like who is this guy
or what is this person what are they
believe in and how does that tie into my
own personal beliefs obviously it's not
a perfect science and people can kind of
like uh present themselves in whatever
they want but I think that like social
media Twitter and and and Instagram
these things specifically have kind of
given people a um a distribution
mechanism to have them have have them
understood um in a way and so you know
when you're spending all day on on x.com
and you're providing context about a
bunch of different topics I think it
allows people to paint a picture of you
that's a little bit more um easy to
understand and maybe honest than you
would get from like a mainstream media
platform and so that's allowed these
voices to become a lot more powerful
these individualized voices to become a
lot more more powerful than they used to
be and I'm sure that you've noticed it
too like how many times you've created
value for yourself just by expressing
your opinion on one of your various
platforms I'm sure that you know what
you found is that it magnetizes the
kinds of people that you want towards
you because you find people who see
things the same way as you do or can at
least um you know combat the way you
think in a way that seems valuable to
you over the long term right and so yeah
I think that having the having a strong
individualized voice in this landscape
um becomes this really useful and
functional tool what's interesting about
it is uh most people think when they're
running a business hey I should not say
anything that will offend someone right
and they very much want to be kind of
cautious and walk on glass uh what you
find is the people who are the best at
it like Elon must piss off a lot of
people but he also pulls this huge
magnet of talent and capital towards him
Palmer lucky another great example we
just go down the line there's a there's
a bunch of these people and so in some
weird way I think my advice has morphed
over the years from like oh you try to
build an audience to like you should
just say what you believe right and like
if you actually believe it and are
willing to say it out loud like there's
some degree of you're willing to defend
that idea in public uh which you will be
you will be shocked at how many other
people believe the same thing and are
impressed that you said it and so then
they will come and they will find you
right and it seems like that's exactly
what you've been doing as well this
episode is brought to you by aradine
there are a brand new startup led by a
number of Silicon Valley Legends who
just raised $81 million to to build the
future of Internet infrastructure you're
probably wondering what that means let
me explain there are numerous new
disruptive technologies that are being
adopted simultaneously from blockchain
to artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin minor powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these air cooled singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
theyve Superior uptime and they leverage
a brand new innovation called Energy
tune that allows miners to dynamically
adjust the energy consumption and
Bitcoin hash rate based on demand
response needs of the electrical grids
aradine is an ambitious company working
on hard problems I'm really impressed
with them and if you want to check out
more you can go to idine.com that's a r
a d i ne.com go check him out at
idine.com today and I yeah totally and I
think that the person who like set this
Playbook up before anybody else and was
like the most honest version of this is
probably Peter teal um you know Peter
has had these contrarian views for you
know decades now and he's never really
been shy of you know like even when the
Trump thing was going down he was very
vocal I think that like Peter is a great
framework for this because he has
constantly spoken his mind and if you
look at teal fellows you look at
Founders fund you look at any of the
companies they're quintessentially teal
um you know they all have this kind of
through line of of of um you know just
like personal and and professional
beliefs and I think that if you can
establish yourself um in a very strong
way with that kind of voice you know to
your point uh the right types of people
will come or not not the right types of
people but the people that you probably
want um coming towards you are are are
uh that's that's just a good way to
attract them so totally on the same page
if we were to take that framework that
he has in terms of his personal beliefs
uh he also has turned that into very
contrarian bets uh in terms of
Investments themselves how do you think
about consensus versus contrarian when
it comes to early stage investing in one
regard uh you maybe want to do something
different and be right very early on but
the whole you know uh framework of
asymmetry is that eventually the
contrarian thing has to become consensus
because that's where the Val value ends
up coming so how do you kind of think
about uh you know hey I want to do
something that is different and find
these out Siz returns but also it has to
be something that maybe eventually gets
to a consensus belief sure yeah I think
that you have to just have like a really
strong um perspective on the macro and
micro and be willing to take your take
like strong bets on that to your point
like the only value that's really AC
like to me I every time I raise a fund
and deploy it I want to raise and deploy
a 10x fund right and there's no way to
get to a TX fund purely off consensus
you have to take these kind of outsize
weird sort of like non obvious bets
because if you were to only take the
obvious bets you know the market is
pretty efficient and they're probably
priced pretty well and so you're going
to see much less of like this outsize
return to you and your investors and so
for me what I always try to balance is
like hey uh there's a certain amount of
things that I have to do that just has
to make sense like it has to fit the
boxes check the boxes because my LPS are
institutions and you know like me doing
these random one-off things is not
necessarily what they put money for me
what they put money into me for and and
I think that that's also a thing that
like you have to be very respectful of
is like at the end of the day if you run
a fund you are like beholden to you know
uh endowments and pensions and all of
these different things and you have to
respect that you can't just like
all of that off with you know just crazy
ideas and in some instances that works
you know but in most instances I think
that there's a fine line of balance
between taking these early bets on these
non-obvious people while also being able
to be somewhat clear voyant into the
future about of like hey if if they hit
if they get to zero to one and they hit
X Y and Z Milestone this actually does
probably become interesting for a
Founders funder this does become
interesting for zqu or an andreon or
whoever else and so it's being sort of
like having some level of premonition of
hey do I think that um X founder withy
idea can basically
get um can basically become a little bit
more consensus over time right and so I
think that understanding what becomes
more consensus over time and who does it
become more consensus to um becomes like
a very important framework to have as a
seed investor because you're really
betting as a seed investor you're really
betting hey this idea becomes more
consensus to these large institutions
over time and so um and and at a point
like it goes from consensus to like a
sequoia to like a consensus to a K2 to a
consensus to like a t price right and
every step of the way you have to
understand like hey does this make sense
for them and so you know I think half of
it is coming up with these new and novel
ideas and trying to capture value early
and then the other half of it is
understanding how do these ideas evolve
into something that's more palatable
over time to larger
audience when you see these consensus or
I'm sorry the contrarian ideas they are
usually started by people who wouldn't
uh pass a normal job interview how do
you how do you kind of uh separate out
who's Crazy versus no who's just
different and is necessary to build the
company and and I say that because uh
through the years I've met and and
sometimes even invested in people who
had these kind of insane ideas that
you're like man if this works this would
be highly highly valuable but then six
months a year two three years down the
road you're like okay but this isn't the
person who's gonna be actually be able
to pull this off versus other times it
is the person who can pull it off and
it's one of the hardest things I think
to do early on when you don't have a
huge you know data set to kind of
evaluate how do you do it the way that I
do it is like and to your point I like
to find people that are unhirable
in other places like could never work at
like an insurance company or like a law
firm or whatever specifically because
they're so obsessed with the idea that
they're working on that they just would
never be able to work anywhere else like
for instance we kind of touched on it a
little bit um earlier uh you know I have
I have a friend named Augustus Doro he's
building a company that's supposed to
like uh be a platform for weather and
and modulate weather and a bunch of
really interesting ways you talk to
Augustus and you talk you see how
passionate he is about things like rain
and things like hurricane G and you
realize like this the there's nothing
else for this guy you know what I mean
like there's no other thing that this
guy could do this is kind of
like this is it you know if this doesn't
work for him like it's you know I don't
know what happens next because he's so
passionate he has so much knowledge and
and I don't know where it's you kind of
like look at these people who are like
oh you're clearly taking an all in bedl
this like everything that you're
teaching yourself your network that
you're building you know the things that
you spend your day to day on are clearly
oriented in such a specific way that
it's like there's no like Plan B it's
literally just you are doing this and if
you're not doing this you're finding a
completely new plan a you know like
you're scrapping everything that you
have going through and like really
literally starting all over and so I
think that I love those people who seem
all in on ideas who are like yo if this
doesn't work I have no idea what else I
have left for me there's no like I just
end up at a law firm somewhere doing
like corporate law or whatever it's like
you know either this is going to work or
I'm back on my buddy's couch figuring
out the next idea and I really like
people who are all in like that and I
think that if you really have sort of an
outsized idea that you want to run with
you kind of have to operate in that way
otherwise you know you're hedging
yourself at a time where you should be
all in the last question I want to ask
is kind of internal uh when it comes to
these uh early stage Venture Capital
firms how do you think about portfolio
construction some people want to go
spread as many Small Checks as possible
and just kind of you know build this
massive index other people are like I
want to take eight to 10 bets and be
highly concentrated what's your strategy
I think it's probably somewhere in
between I don't love the idea of like
having a bunch of and and I think that
like if you're honest with yourself um
at seed and you really want to do you
really do want to be helpful to these
companies um you have to be honest with
like how much work you're actually able
to do um and so to me it's like much
less useful for me to do 150k checks um
and just sort of index the market
because at the end of the day your
you'll get a market return you know like
there's there'll be nothing special
about your return you you'll basically
just be kind of like in the median of
whatever that that return profile is
right I think that to be really
effective especially at the seed stage
you kind of have to take bigger Bets
with a smaller amount of total bets um
and and for me that allows you to work
closely with these companies in a way
that you can see value outsize value
returning to you as an investor and your
investors in your fund um and so to me
the right number I have a $20 million
fund it'll probably end up with 30 to 35
companies at a median check size of
called 600 to 750k um and that'll
probably be you know where I net out and
and I think that that is enough
ownership upfront where you're not
getting I mean you probably still get
crazy diluted but at least through that
delution you'll still end up with a
healthy amount of percentage and um
you're not spreading yourself super thin
where you're trying to help 50 companies
every week you know and when you see you
know we talk about the media stuff but I
guess like also if you're writing those
size checks early on uh you're below the
threshold where it's highly competitive
how much of the deal flow is coming
inbound on Twitter versus uh kind of
personal networks of individuals versus
uh large institutions you know other
other VC firms that are kind of sending
you deals yeah I think that I'm I'm
really lucky in the sense that I seem to
be pretty neutral and most people uh
find working with me totally fine and so
uh I I'm lucky in the sense that you
know and I'm sure you have this too
since you you have quite a big platform
yourself is I just have an email that's
like latently available for Founders to
send me whatever I probably get anywhere
on the order of 75 to 100 deals a week
uh maybe four to 5% of those are really
interesting and worth diving in more um
what's also great about having a
platform as I'm sure you know is that my
the cold Outreach uh conversion
percentage is quite High you know I can
reach out to Founders and at the very
least they'll be like who the is
this random meme page uh you know asking
about my company I might as well see at
the very least what's going on here and
then when you can articulate like hey
I'm actually I actually take this quite
seriously I'm a student of the game I
have a lot of value and and people that
I think that I could be able to provide
to you um you know then it becomes a
little bit more of an interesting
conversation um and so yeah I think that
what's the right balance for me is
working closely with a bunch of the
funds in the valley who I'm very lucky
to to work with quite closely as well as
trying to find net new things so that it
never seems one-sided in that exchange
right so it's not like oh I'm just
taking de flow from SEO every single day
and they get nothing back it's you know
I give them one thing I I send them one
thing they send me one thing and we just
go back and forth until you know
hopefully we've done a we've
cross-pollinated a bunch of stuff and
I'm really into being collaborative in
that kind of way I think that there are
some people who are like weirdly not
weirdly I understand where comes from
but they're very focused on just like
acre all of this stuff to themselves and
to me I think that you know over time
you are going to have to work with these
people in some capacity so it might as
well be earlier than later um and build
making sure that you know you are sorted
in a good way uh when that when that
time comes that makes uh makes complete
sense to me it sounds ridiculous to ask
but where can people find you if if they
want to send you deals yeah you can just
any uh any social media platform you
just type in praying for exits I'm sure
I'll pop up and if not um g p like
General partner um at praying for exits
is another great place to reach me I'm
I'm very active there so um yeah reach
out awesome I appreciate you doing this
uh I learned something which always
makes these great and uh I think that
you are helping to Pioneer a whole new
model where uh your identity doesn't
matter nearly as much the quality of
your work and uh your kind of value of
the pseudonym actually is uh driven by
by uh the word of mouth right you help
one founder they go tell everyone else
and then all of a sudden you became
known as a super high quality high value
uh kind of addition to a cap table and
uh then there is this element of like
everyone's still a kid at heart and you
know likes the idea of let's get this
the the uh pseud Anonymous VC on on the
cap table as well totally awesome well
all right thank you so much we'll do it
again in the future yes thank you man I
appreciate it